- [Ben] Hi, I'm Ben.
- [Ahmed] Hi, I'm Ahmed and today
we're making one of my favorite
childhood dishes, chicken shawarma.
- [Ben] It's actually one
of my childhood dishes also.
I remember going by the ...
Some are like, actually
pizza places in New York
would also have the shawarma.
- [Ahmed] It's funny, I feel like shawarma
is to Aleppo what pizza is to New York.
I just vividly remember the memories
of my mom sending me to the store.
You have the chicken, and then
you have this garlic sauce,
which we'll be making later today.
And, that's the magic.
It's amazing, that's so good.
- It really is good.
- We should just do that
for the rest of the video.
- [Ben] We met last year.
- [Ahmed] Yeah, almost exactly a year ago.
- [Ben] Yeah, at World
Refugee Day at the U.N.
Because I had been doing
some work with UNHCR,
Union Refugee Agency.
You were reading a poem there.
- [Ahmed] Yes, I wrote a poem called,
A Thank You Letter, from the bomb
that visited my home 11 years ago.
So, it's from the perspective of the bomb
talking to me after all these years.
I was eight, eight years old.
This was in 2006.
So, we had to flee Iraq in 2006.
We literally just got on a bus.
And, as a kid, you don't
really realize these things.
You don't understand that you
might be leaving your home
for the very last time.
- [Ben] And the first place you
lived in the U.S. was where?
- [Ahmed] Sioux Falls, South Dakota.
- [Ben] Wow, how's the
shawarma in Sioux Falls?
- [Ahmed] Ah, it's not very good.
We moved around a few times in the U.S.
and shawarma wasn't always right there.
Living in the states, and having to create
this dish at home, as opposed
to getting it down the street.
I should ask my dad, why
didn't we make life choices
based on where shawarma
is readily available?
- Pretty good, yeah.
- There's like that little aftertaste.
- Yeah, it has a little,
a little zing at the end.
It's kind of perfect.
- [Ahmed] Right.
- [Ben] And seriously, how did you guys
end up in South Dakota?
- [Ahmed] When you flee your home,
and then you apply for refugee status,
it's a very, very, very long process.
We found out one summer
day we were in Jubla.
I remember I was in my bedroom,
my mom was in the living
room, all of a sudden
I just hear screaming.
I'm like, "Oh my God.
"Did she find out that I
did that thing yesterday?"
You know and then, I walk in and then
she kind of just puts the
phone down and she's like,
"Ahmed, we're going to America."
When they told her on the phone they said,
"You have four one way tickets to
"Sioux Falls, South Dakota."
- [Ben] Idea of what a
refugee is in people's minds,
there's an image there that doesn't really
correlate with reality.
It's not something you choose.
They're looking for an opportunity
just to have a life.
- [Ahmed] Exactly.
And, when we first came
to the states, you know,
my parents had to find jobs.
They had to figure out
how to make ends meet.
Americans have to do that, as well.
We have to start thinking
of the common thread
through these experiences.
It doesn't have to be this
foreign, foreign thing.
- Cheers, okay.
- Cheers.
There's this like, amazing
familiarity that happens
like, right mid-bite.
You're transported somewhere else,
and you're reminded of not
only just like the food,
but the people that prepared it.
- Yeah, and really I'm just like
struck by the, how much I like to eat.
Food, I love food.
- [Narrator] Oh, yes!